vous êtes en quête d'adrénaline ou bien
vous souhaitez offrir un cadeau
inoubliable alors pourquoi ne pas offrir
une expérience dans les
[Musique]
airs l'école d'aviation tomka à
l'aérodrome de saint-sirlécole propose
des vols découvertes en ULM vous pourrez
profiter des magnifiques paysages
yvelinois et parisiens avec des vues sur
le château de Versailles la tour
effffelle et même parfois le sacré cœur
et ce à partir de 110 €. et si vous vous
sentez l'âme d'un pilote vous pourrez
aussi choisir le vol d'initiation ou
après un brief sur les bases du pilotage
c'est vous qui tiendrez les commandes
avec la présence bien sûr d'un
instructeur et le prix de départ 165 €
alors n'attendez plus et vivez une
expérience à couper le
souffle